hi I'm Doug Walker from channel awesome
at the end of our most popular show
nostalgia critic we always do a charity
shout out encouraging people to donate
well they've done well we realize not
everybody's in a financial situation
where they can give but everybody at
some point or another can give time so
every month we're gonna try and show a
new charity or organization that you can
help out with there's so many people in
difficult circumstances but thankfully
there's always people who are willing to
help and you can be one of them whether
it's volunteering or lending a helping
hand we're here to show you what you can
do
[Music]
I'm Michele Szarkowski and I'm with the
Oak Park River forest food pantry and
how long is this place been here it's
been over for 40 years you know
celebrating the 40th anniversary this
year our mission is to end hunger so we
do all we can to do that our biggest
program I think it's our name people are
most familiar with it is the food pantry
so that's a system where people come in
they shop for groceries they leave with
about a week's worth of food and they
can come once a month
hunger exists beyond the four walls of
this building and so we try to reach
hunger where it is one of the things is
the home delivery project and that is
for people who physically can't make it
into the pantry so a lot of elderly
people disabled people people with
mental health disabilities that can't
come in so we call them up ask them what
they want to eat put together you know
several bags worth of groceries and
deliver it to their home
hi I'm Ricardo Garcia and the pantry and
volunteer manager here they are part of
a forest food pantry now someone wants
to volunteer what process do they have
to go through I mean there's a lot
various ways you can volunteer but let's
say they want to come here and help out
yeah so individual volunteers who are
interested basically we have to go
through an orientation where we explain
what our mission is where our vision is
and the values that we hold here at the
pantry and I also explain the portal we
have a volunteer portal where every
volunteer gets their own you know
personal login and it's able to see the
schedule and see how they want to get
involved we also have a program in the
summer kids you know they get free and
reduced lunch during the school year
when summer is on there's no school
there's no food for those kids so we
have some variety of summer programs
that are targeting those children to
make sure that they get food when we
have people come in to shop at the food
pantry they wait in this large waiting
room and sometimes people have to wait
quite a while if we've got a hundred or
150 people coming on a day you're gonna
wait a little bit if you're here waiting
for your chance to shop then one of the
things that we do is sneak in some
education so we unique among pantries in
the region having nutrition
education program and so we have a
couple dietitians we have several
Dietetic interns that come in and they
will do a presentation on a particular
topic one month so it might be diets
that are good for hypertension and then
they'll do perhaps a food sample with
food from the food pantry
they'll give some recipes they'll talk
to people about what their disease
states are and what they know about diet
and then help people shop through that
way what are some of the various
different ways that people can volunteer
absolutely and so volunteers are able to
choose whether they want to be involved
with clients directly so those are
client-facing shifts and so or if they
just want to be like I call it backstage
they want to help bagging sorting
through donations when we have food
drives we always have a big need for
groups or many volunteers to come and
help us check every date every you know
condition of every product I also offer
cooking classes a few times a year and
we do take people to stores to actually
give them a tour of a store and say this
is how you shop when you're looking to
manage your diet for diabetes on a snap
budget snap is the Supplemental
Nutrition Assistance Program foods names
you're talking before about something
that you're gonna start along those
lines that sort of shows what foods you
can kind of have in bulk and what
programs it's a traffic light system
like red foods or things that you should
stay away from yellow foods are things
that you should eat but in moderation
and green foods are things you can have
all the time so a green food would be
all of your fresh fruits and vegetables
and a yellow food might be a protein
like you peanut butter for instance it's
a protein you need some of it but it's
also fairly high in fat and salt so you
don't want to eat a ton of it and then
red foods would be you know pie all the
time but you know once in a while it's
fine when I came into this I mean
obviously I know why food pantry is but
I didn't know too much detail about
there's a lot of things I found out like
I didn't know you could actually there's
like a menu you can choose from stuff
and I always thought well whatever is
there is that's kind of what you're
given but they can actually go and
choose what they like you look out for
allergies as well and stuff like that
what's a perception that people probably
have about food pantries that aren't
true or what's something that maybe
people aren't aware of when they come to
I think that people often think it's a
really sad you know our place but it's
not this is a really friendly welcoming
place we often have a musician that
plays for people while they're in the
waiting room there's this interactive
aspect where you're learning something
new when you come people get to shop on
their own so we have categories of
products so for instance there's of
beans section and there's a meat meal
section and people can choose within
those sections and it matches up to
their family size so we try to focus on
equity and those kinds of ways making
sure that it's fair across the continuum
people that we serve there must be a lot
of interesting stories here people who
want to help out what are some of the
most like amazing stories you've heard
the musician he comes in twice a month
in place for our clients for free just
because he wanted to give back to the
community in that kind of way we had a
woman recently her company instead of
giving holiday gifts to their clients
decided what they would do was support
their employees their passions around
nonprofits and so they gave each person
a certain amount of money and said you
know donate this in our behalf and so
what this person did was did a cooking
demonstration and provided some of the
food from that demonstration telev
clients and then got so engaged in it
from there she ended up buying cookbooks
for people he's now volunteering in the
home delivery program every month she
recruits a bunch of people around that
it's interesting to me how people can
have a little one little entree in and
then get so excited and keep building on
in different ways somebody gave me a
journal now you should keep a journal of
all the cool things that happen that's
so cool exactly right because there's so
much to happen here and one of the
things that for me really touches me I
live in this community is to see how
this is literally literally the
definition of community you see groups
you know it's just it's almost like it's
a good problem to have everybody jumps
in anything that happens the government
shutdown happen everyone jumps in such
an incredible energy that we have in
this community same thing with the food
drive same thing with the holidays
everyone wants to volunteer everybody
wants to donate and to me that's like
one of the coolest thing that I've
learned in these three years that this
community has really surprised me
you know it's really surprising to see
how interested how eager how
compassionate this community really is
that's one of the things I love about
this with both volunteering and just
people donating stuff is there's all
sorts of various ways that people can
help out like the musician who would
have thought you know that that's a
great thing
now this organisation has a ton of
various ways you can volunteer
what are just a handful of those ways
because I know there's it's hard for all
of the programs that we have there we
there's a need for volunteers right for
the food pantry itself when people are
shopping through that whole food pantry
we use about 60 volunteers every
Saturday for that process drives food
drives or diaper drives that people do
some people really like to interact with
people and so they'll want to volunteer
at the food pantry itself so they can
help somebody shop for instance and
there are some people that really like a
more background sort of position and so
they might be doing things like at the
home delivery packing up the bags to
deliver to people people also can't buy
any kind of toiletries for food stamps
so sometimes we'll have people do drives
around like razors and shaving cream
which you need if you want to have a job
right but you know you can't buy that
with food stamps so you know things like
that are various ways that people can
engage on multiple different levels but
are some of the best times that people
get no absolutely we are lucky that we
have again a lot of opportunities so
people can as I mentioned some of the
things that they can do they can also go
to the different rescue partners we have
15 different rescue partners and rescue
partners at the grocery stores here in a
neighborhood that are donating food
they're donating on average about 15,000
pounds per month so I need people to go
pick it up I need people to literally
take the time to go to these grocery
stores you know all them hoards and
Jewel Osco and all those places and go
in the afternoons every Wednesday
afternoon we have our distributions and
as I mentioned is 45 volunteers calm and
then Saturdays to double that so
Saturday's about 90 volunteers come from
8 a.m. all the way to about 1 p.m. so
for us those families who have jobs or
happiness school or anything like that
is Saturday is a perfect opportunity to
come and spend you know 3 hours with us
doing something that is very meaningful
but also meeting you know other members
of the community and engaging in that
way an easy thing is
to an event great so we have a big
concert event in the fall this spring
we've got a great event coming up which
is the healthy chef challenge so it's
kind of like chopped meats the food
pantry so what we do is we give people
food from the food pantry and it's a
surprise there are chefs and they
compete to see who can make the most
delicious meal that's everything yeah
and we give them I think a couple days
notice on what most of the items are but
then there's a surprise and so last year
the evil surprise was SpaghettiOs is it
like Iron Chef that's like the secret
ingredient was tragic for some of these
chefs but it was super fun you can
become a monthly donor you can attend
any of our other events you know a lot
of groups to volunteer as a group which
is a really interesting way to do things
so we have corporate groups that come in
and do sort of like team-building
bonding exercises we have church groups
congregations of various sorts that
volunteer together so there are those
kinds of options where you can you know
bond with your friends or your community
in a broader way while also giving back
to a broader community there's so many
people there like what we're gonna do
today I don't know you know they can't
think of anything and it's like if
you're gonna just be laying around doing
nothing it's like just coming somewhere
and doing something so easy like you
said just packing oranges or just moving
stuff or games it's like it can be
helping people learn more about what the
issues are in your community 15% of the
population of our communities is food
insecure something people don't know we
also serve 13 zip code so we serve the
west side of Chicago as well where food
insecurity rates are up to like 37% so
it's a huge issue in our area but one
that often goes under the radar because
you can't see a hunger person that
education and that broader community
understanding I think is an important
part of the work that we do as well talk
about this kid that saw there weren't
many diapers available and just sort of
took this idea rapidly his story's
amazing yeah yeah so we had this was
many years ago so I did a presentation
at a real estate agency
and the woman can went home and she was
talking to her sister who had a young
child about that and she was one of the
things that surprised her was you
couldn't buy diapers with food stamps
and so their little boy Amy was there
listening to this I think he was six at
the time and he got very upset about it
and so he went to his room got his piggy
bank and came back to his mom and said
can you take this money and buy diapers
it's just like out of a hallmark I know
the next year he decided he wanted to do
it again and he had figured out on his
own so now he's like seven that adults
sometimes need diapers too and so he
asked his mom to buy some adult diapers
and then he's just continued to build
this program I think he got a lot of
positive feedback like what we're doing
right now right he's turned it into a
whole fundraising campaign he does every
year this year he drove up with a u-haul
full of diapers every size of diaper
every size of child diaper every size of
adult diaper and didn't you say like he
also threw out like the opening pitch at
yeah yeah he threw out the opening pitch
at the Sox game a couple of years ago
what is the surplus project your close
project yeah I know this awesome so we
have our main goal is to end hunger but
we also are very concerned about food
waste and so one of our priorities is to
make sure there's as little waste as
possible and one of the programs that
we've developed I think it's now five
years old is called the surplus project
and so what we do is we partner with
cafeterias we partner with a number of
hospitals and some university and high
schools and at the end of the day at the
cafeteria there's food leftover and
instead of throwing it out
we now have them package it into
individual meals so then those meals are
distributed to us and we also pass them
on to other agencies that serve people
that are food insecure so it's a way to
get food out of the waste stream to
people who need it and in a really can
for the end of the day I don't want to
go home and prepare an entire meal with
dried beans and all the beautiful foods
that we give people sometimes I just
need some convenient food if I've had a
late meeting and so free people that we
serve who might work in the evening now
they can come home and they get like a
premade meal which is a something that
they wouldn't be able to afford on their
own but is this wonderful nutritious
food that would normally have been
thrown out because people don't know
what to do with it I think it's
wonderful not only what what you do here
but that's just so many people that want
to give and so many organizations want
to give and just every little thing and
individual ones to give a group wants to
give and you utilize all of it I can
just say I have it's kind of different
ideas of what a food pantry was like how
I use it I mean it's like the only thing
oh it's gonna be kind of like a downer
place but you do but that is very
positive it is very upbeat and there's
so many various ways that people can
help out and volunteer if they want to
volunteer or they want to donate when
you look right that camera and tell them
where they can go online
www.opm.gov/openseason
[Music]